I want to call Brad Williams cuz he
remember you know this Quaid in bales
thing that I do yeah the young gunner
this Australian young buck Ryan and uh
and people were really lighting into him
yeah but the right and Brad did a
fundraiser for him and it was supposed
to be to raise ten grand and I think
they raised about a lot more I'm gonna
say couple hundred dollars then
unfortunately hold on okay
sorry don't hold you say whatever you
want yes I was gonna say I'm sorry
pictures pictures of that kid came out
with him with strippers and stuff like
that did they really so I don't think
he's eight year I don't they say he's
not eight or nine years old but I don't
care he's still small enough he still
can't get on all the rides so we should
still just send him out there well I
mean if you want I don't know what
happened so what I'm wondering is do we
know what happened and you guys are
gonna have to put on the headphones to
hear Brad when we call them I mean
$300,000 is a lot of [ __ ] money
I don't know Brad's number alright cuz
this thing really captivated the nation
last week and put the phone in little
middle of table hey brother what's up
man it's Theo hey buddy how are you
amen thanks for answering the call I'm
uh we got Chris de Stefano here in the
podcast right now and Brad yes on
Thursday man we're gonna do Kimmel
together oh yell our little stand up yet
duet we showed we could do that I'm down
to do that yeah Brad only of Christmas
on your lap great let your hand up my
ass my favorite section is a reverse
Jeff Dunham at the at the cathouse in
Vegas let's do it dude that's why I'll
stay an extra night then you don't need
an extra night for you to stop by during
the day alright I'll do that I'll be
that creeper that hangs out in broad
daylight cathouse
you're gonna be living in the apartments
Brad we had a we talked about the quaint
embarrassing on podcast last week and
and everybody's been talking about it I
know that you did a fundraiser for him
can you kind of take us through a little
bit of that and where you're at now with
it yeah no problem
first of all he's nine years old
everybody okay so stop with your damn
conspiracy theories he's nine years old
anyway I got I got wind of the video
because I've got some Australian fans
that kept sending me the video and I
don't know like why they kept sending it
to me just like hey you're a dwarf he's
a dwarf you can help him like I'd like I
don't know I don't know what they were
yeah like I've got some hot line yeah
but I saw but I saw the video and like
anyone who saw the video he's got a
pulse I was really moved by it of course
of course I'm I'm a fellow little person
he's got the same kind of dwarfism that
I do and I was bullied growing up so it
really it it really spoke to me so I
thought I got to do something but I
can't you know I'm out in Los Angeles
what can I do he's in Australia so I
thought well I'll throw together a
GoFundMe page and send the kid to
Disneyland I grew up going at Disneyland
kids love Disneyland so I did that to
set the goal at ten thousand dollars
goes with ten thousand dollars you can
buy them flights tickets and maybe two
churros
yeah I figured you know that that'd be
that'd be a good time so instead of ten
thousand dollars tweeted it out and then
I went to bed and the next day it was an
$18,000 and then Hugh Jackman talked
about it William Shatner talked about it
it started getting passed around all
these celebrities and then currently
we're at four hundred and sixty thousand
dollars yeah so Theo get for a weekend
oh boy is gonna buy Disneyland
and I'm thrilled about that I hope with
dwarf owns Disneyland's and probably no
more height requirements all day and so
whenever the whenever the the the
conspiracy theories came out I mean just
because you know people are skeptical
ever everything what did you do then oh
man I just kind of let it go like if I
chase down every person that was talking
about it or saying that he's 18 years
old or that he's he's not really 18 he's
a 45 year old actor people saying he's
in Dunkirk he was in John Curtin people
lair were they dropping him out of the
plane dropping them onto the Germans
yeah people were there were all kinds of
conspiracy theories people were saying
that he worked for the city I remember
somewhere else out of Akron there was
all kind of wild stuff but did you did
you check with him did you do any other
recon to make sure that you were like
did you have any question yeah I mean I
just wanted to make sure that he's a
good kid and that you know he's a kid
but I got the face time with him and
FaceTime though and his mom and that's
back when the fundraiser was at 20,000
dollars and it really hadn't picked up
yet new news organizations weren't
really talking about it so I was
facetiming with him he seems like a fun
normal kid and then once it started
going above like $50,000 $75,000 I
started reaching out to a bunch of
different people that run charities and
do these kind of thing things all things
all the time
GoFundMe is an incredible website
because once a fundraiser hits a certain
point they assign a team to that
fundraiser so I had a team from GoFundMe
and constant constant communication and
they vetted everything they they looked
and everything they did amazing work so
and and yet where does the money go well
and we posted an update on the page
so Caden and his family actually
released a statement that said that they
are turning down the trip Disneyland and
they want all the money to just go to
charity
Wow so let's go in he's ridiculous are
using like the charities he picked the
charity how does it work
I did another FaceTime call with him and
and his mom and we kind of went through
all all the charities that we wanted to
go through because if you look at the
original wording on my GoFundMe I said
any excess money would be donated to
charity hmm
so we we picked some great charities and
they're actually posted right now on the
GoFundMe page
we picked six different charities tomato
sauce charity run yeah it's now I stomp
out bullying uh born this way those are
two charities in the United States
there's four charities in in in
Australia we're giving about sixty six
thousand dollars to each of those
charities and then whatever money is
left over I I decided to give it to
Caden and his family and said you guys
can spend that money however you want I
know you're turning down money but many
people donated to this fund with the
thought of their money going directly to
the family
and it's honor and is it four hundred
thousand US or Australian over seven
hundred thousand Australian oh they
could buy one of those [ __ ] they
could buy the aborigine people all right
not all of them you could buy probably a
couple absolutely as do i person have
you look i would i would love to meet
one i know because i have uh I don't
think I have any Aborigine fans but I'm
looking for that that's one of the
things I'm trying to get from my podcast
there you go
you got a gilt and yeah and and I and I
Brad to because you know cuz I'm only
I'm just a victim of the internet as
well it's like all these pictures are
like always
nineteen years old he's with strippers
he's got guns I mean how do they do all
that like what like what is it was
Photoshop the Internet is an amazing
place both good and bad I mean there
were there were people that were
spreading rumors that like oh like there
was some like I looked at oh yeah this
stuff because I want to make sure that
the that the money was going to a good
spot there was one person who had a
Facebook talk show that said like that
Caden was like this nine-year-old
running around the school like sexually
assaulting girls men I mean that they
they said that they're proof was that
they read one Facebook comment that's
and they post the Facebook comment and
it said oh a friend of mine his his kid
goes to the same school and knows some
girls was this happen I'm like really
you're going through all this off of
Facebook come yeah that's yeah do you is
there I mean yeah there's all kind of
stuff so many people said he opened up
for gucci mane there was all Kanye's
well that that is the problem is when
UTA signs him and he starts taking dates
away from everybody looking back [ __ ]
you Brad they signed bagel boy bagel
boss
yeah they had this kid named lightning
rod lightning rod I don't wanna say
lightning rod lightning rod me maybe
when I was growing up somehow they got
hit by lightning and they try to tow him
around locally really yeah he was
probably moving major tickets I wouldn't
do anything made forty tickets not gonna
sell out now what about this bread are
there higher costs associated with being
like a little person growing up like are
there costs that are there extra costs
yeah well like just in terms of I mean
at your hosts basic cost most clothes
that I would like to buy don't fit me so
you gotta get stuff that tailored unless
you just want to be walking around with
like a shirt that has Bob the Builder on
it but right out you want that so yeah
you have extra tailoring and then plus a
lot of little people
medical problems whether it be neck or
leg surgeries I've had one dwarf related
surgery on my legs so yeah they can they
didn't get problems that way as well so
that's why I wanted to give the family a
little bit of money just because if
those kind of things are coming up with
Caden I want to make sure that they're
taken care of and that's what people who
gave money to the campaign want it as
well so that's dope yeah yeah and it's
really great and really in and people
stepped up and we ended up donating a
ton of money to charity that's going to
anti-bullying and anti abuse anti racism
charities so a lot of people are a lot
of people are gonna be helped in a very
positive way because of this yeah not be
more thankful yeah man and I know you
know and cuz you're I'm a I'm a dad I
know you're a new dad Congrats it's like
when I stand up like that and I'm sure
it's the same with you it's like you
can't help but think like what if that
was my child being abused that way like
you know so it's great that you can that
you made an effort and did it cuz I
there's thing there's times when I see
videos like that I'm like I can't what
if that was my daughter and then I have
a chance to donate and I just watch porn
hub or do something different but you
actually went out there and made a
difference which is why you're happily
married and I'm you know single living
with Don Zepeda on his couch I still
yeah that's why I got visitation rights
but you you know but you have a full
happy family there's still time thanks
so much man and yeah at least Chris will
be warmed up for your podcast later this
week man hey before he hangs up can you
hear me yeah what's the quickest way to
get to your GoFundMe because when you
just search on GoFundMe we can't find it
so how can we get to the actual GoFundMe
oh if you guys still want to donate to
the GoFundMe because it is still open
you can probably quickest way is just to
go to my Twitter and then scroll down
the tweets and you'll find you'll find
links I'm on Twitter at funny Brad and
if not I'm sure you can just google
GoFundMe for a bullied Australian boy
and something's gonna pop up there will
be news articles there will be links
you can and then $460,000 in there
already so yeah I know and I had so many
friends that were like it really makes
you realize who your friends are because
I had so many friends that were like
sending me messages like dude embezzle
it take it go to Sweden [ __ ] what if you
disguised yourself as Quaid and then
went to Disneyland
[Laughter]
it could happen man
dude dude thanks so much it's such a
it's such a cool story to hear man and
um yeah just thanks for jumping on the
line with this isn't sharing that no
problem guys love the podcast see see on
Thursday Chrissie Thursday Brad good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one